welcome back to CBS this morning seven
Democratic candidates for president
clashed in Los Angeles last night for
the final debate of 2019 this year's
almost done they largely agreed on the
problems facing America but disagreed
sharply on how to solve them senators
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
stood on either side of former Vice
President Joe Biden both attacking his
health care plan it was also the first
debate since the president's impeachment
an issue one candidate feels is
overblown what we have to do is we have
to stop being obsessed over impeachment
which unfortunately strikes many
Americans like a ball game where you
know what the score is going to be and
start actually digging in and solving
the problems that god Donald Trump
elected in the first place
the standout moment of the night may
have been a heated exchange between
Lauren and mayor Pete Budaj
over a recent lavish fundraiser he
attended in California's Napa Valley
we made the decision many years ago that
rich people in smoke-filled rooms would
not pick the next president of the
United States billionaires in wine caves
should not pick the next president of
the United States mr. mayor your
response you know according to Forbes
magazine
I am the literally the only person on
this stage who's not a millionaire or a
billionaire so if this is the problem
with issuing purity tests you cannot
yourself pass CBS News political
contributors Robby Mook and Terry
Sullivan are here to discuss Robby as
you know as Hillary Clinton's 2016
campaign manager Terry Sullivan just a
nice guy was also say manager obviously
a nice guy too but Jerry and I bonded
over the Nationals champion okay guys
let's start with the debate but with the
debate last night they came after Pete
Buddha judges this is a sign that he
they're worried about him Robby yeah
Iowa polling was driving so much of what
was going on last night right so Buddha
judge is only leading in in Iowa polling
sometimes in Newham
but certainly nationally you know his
numbers are totally different and he's
stealing votes from Warren and so that
entire engagement was about trying to
change the dynamics and Iowa clove
Acharya saw getting in there a bunch she
you know Iowa is her chance so that's
what was really going on here and what
was interesting out of that was Biden
was kind of left alone right he has
multiple paths he doesn't have to win
Iowa and so you know you just saw that
dynamic play out right now it was only
45 days away so the pressure here well
and and look there have only been in
modern history to Democrats to get the
nomination by not winning Iowa first so
I mean it matters a lot it's a big prize
only two that have gotten the nomination
and not won Iowa and so this matters a
lot in these candidates on this stage
this is not an accident they weren't
attacking booter judge because because
they didn't like him they had a mission
when they went up on stage and he was
the most attacked man so they're seeing
something and their numbers and their
data that says how do you think he
responded really well I have a really
good job you know it was it he was so
prepared right he had he had a really
good point to make and he delivered it
you know with with style it didn't feel
cans and it didn't feel defensive also
and look I thought it got to this meta
point we heard President Obama weigh in
on this about canceled culture you know
I think he was making a very fair point
it may not be as memorable though as
hash tag wine cave P what happens in
those wine cakes do you think Elizabeth
Warren did herself a favor by pursuing
that line of attack her whole candidacy
she has tact really hard to say look I'm
trying to take the influence of money
out of politics so I think it was right
along with her message she needs to
create distinctions from the other
candidate so you know I I think it was
probably the right thing for her to do
but man he was really prepared to look
at the end of the day the voters aren't
deciding who they're going to vote for
who they're going to nominate
based on you know where they're doing
their fundraisers I just think that's
kind of inside baseball that campaigns
get bogged down onto a lot and voters
want someone who's gonna go and take out
being able take on Donald Trump
candidate the candidates tacked away
from impeachment when it came up how are
they handling this do you think
they're trying not to cry and for two
reasons one is I don't think they all
agree so I don't really think I mean
tulsi gabbard had that odd vote but I
don't think she's really relevant don't
seem to be talking about it on the road
right so they don't need to address it
and I thought yang did a brilliant job
articulating this we need to have
something to tell voters we're gonna do
for them this isn't just about
disqualifying Trump we need to offer our
own point of view so I thought that was
very well said and I think that yeah but
not a message not a message that
Democrat primary voters probably want to
hear I mean you know better than I would
but but this measured reasonable oh we
should we should get beyond impeachment
isn't something the base of the Democrat
Party seems to be motivated but I think
there's a cross pressure I think they
want the the president impeached exactly
want they want people to check that box
but then they don't want people to do
all on it they have one thought the
president certainly made it clear when
it comes to impeachment nothing to see
here let's move along they're out to get
me they're out to get you my base do you
think that his message will go beyond
his base yeah and I don't think he wants
a long term yes such as I think it will
I forgot actual data we you know my firm
firehouse strategies we've done polling
in these battleground states and
regularly do it with these swing voters
you know these swing voters two-thirds
of them want to move on that they are
they don't care about the impeachment
they care about prescription drugs and
health care and taxes and issues that
are affecting them and they see this is
just a sideshow an example that that
Congress isn't doing anything that's a
memo to Democrats but also memo the to
the president real often likes to talk
about impeachment but this is the irony
right so he's gonna try to have it both
ways he's gonna continue to talk about
impeachment to say that's all the
Democrats still all day they're not
fighting for you I am and that's why
they're impeaching me but in fact he's
gonna continue to dwell on it management
so the question is can he get
can he get away I mean it's a strike
it's really been is his natural strength
is taking perceived weaknesses and
making them a strength and then beating
the ever-loving crud out of out of his
opponents with that which started off as
a weakness all right everything cried
everliving morning so I want
that we do very much we'll see back real
soon
you